we try to look at every aspect of our
life that's changed because of the
pandemic and one of the biggest is how
we work those of us lucky enough to
still have a job have had to adapt we're
getting the work done from our kitchens
or our couches pajamas are the new
business suit what's that done though to
the millions of square meters of office
space around the world much of it is
empty now and it could stay that way for
a long time
Jackson Prosecco explores the future of
offices in a building in Falls Church
Virginia
we found what may be the workplace of
the future an office retrofitted and
ready for the era of kovat 19 at least
that's the hope people have seen some of
the things that we're doing and they
want to incorporate it into their
offices as well christian Pinkston has
been working to get his company prepared
for it's uncertain next steps figuring
out what it will take to welcome staff
back into the office the concept of just
a deeper cleaning once or twice a day
isn't going to be enough and because
once you bring people back into the
space it's it's instantly contaminated
again in the US and Canada there are few
guidelines for how offices should
operate in a pandemic
so Kingston developed his own playbook
taking a gamble on technology starting
with this ultraviolet cleanse portal the
new front door they'll go through this
portal kind of slowly they'll pause
they'll do a slow turn they're making
sure that all that you know the surfaces
of their hands and in clothes are
exposed to the UV lighting and so it's
it's cleansing them of any microbes
viruses bacteria they might be carrying
with them and anything they're carrying
as well so if I step into this I mean
I'm not seeing anything there's a little
bit of like a faint a faint light and a
faint sound but that's it that purple
glow is UVC light known for its germ
zapping abilities Pinkston has also
installed UVC fixtures in high-traffic
areas like the kitchen along with
specialized air filters we know that
Karuna virus will spread through
the air droplets and so that's a major
risk factor and so we've installed an
air sanitizing troffer in this room
that's constantly recirculating the air
and in with a very powerful UVC light
inside of it then there are the
invisible changes special sensors detect
if there's virus in the air every
surface is now covered in an
antimicrobial coating of titanium
dioxide we wanted to do something that
was realistic financially but we wanted
to do as much as we could within that
parameter to provide the safest possible
environment the reality is that offices
are the kind of places where kovat 19
can thrive full of shared surfaces close
quarters and long days of uncontrolled
contact researchers in South Korea
discovered how easily the virus can
spread in that environment
after a cluster of 97 employees at a
call center in Seoul tested positive for
kovat 19 when health officials looked
closer they found 94 of them work
together on the same floor and 79 of
them sat in the same section of the
office nearly half of the workers on
that one floor ended up getting sick to
make sure that doesn't happen again
offices and office buildings will have
to take drastic steps from top to bottom
professor Joseph Allen is an expert in
healthy buildings we have to employ some
of these healthy building strategies
like bringing more fresh outdoor air to
dilute the airborne contaminants and
filter the recirculated air using
high-efficiency filters that's just one
small part of a multi-layered defense
desks will have to be spaced at least
two metres apart high-walled cubicles
may have to make a comeback employees
and visitors will be subjected to
temperature checks don't be surprised if
everyone has to wear a mask kitchens and
common areas will likely be off-limits
even the little things like pictures and
trinkets on desks will likely disappear
to make way for daily deep cleaning if
you layer enough defenses on top of each
other you make it really difficult in
this case of security
for a bad actor to penetrate your system
right same thing with this virus if you
layer enough of these defenses on top of
each other you don't eliminate risk
there's no such thing as zero risk you
get it to a point where it can become
manageable and to a level where people
can feel comfortable coming back into
your building the elevator may be the
biggest hurdle there's just no way
around it expect a limit on how many
people can ride at a time and then
imagine what that means in a building
like New York's One World Trade Center
where 8,000 workers are spread across 90
floors and so the easiest solution may
just be for companies to keep some
people working from home staggering
shifts or alternating days to have fewer
people in the office at any given time I
think one thing that it has taught
people is that you can remote you can
work remotely and you can do it
effectively now the things you can't do
effectively I think that's what we're
gonna lean on the office for Albert day
plays Ola is the director of global
strategy for the design firm unis base
he sees kovat 19 changing the role of
the office forever Canadian tech giant
Shopify has already declared the era of
office centricity is over employees will
stay working from home until 2021 after
that the office will be for specific
uses only not an everyday destination
twitter has gone even further telling
staff they can work from home forever if
they want to now we've done a ton of
surveys with organizations we're getting
a lot of we get we're getting a lot of
feedback and input from CFOs and what
we're seeing is that at least forty to
sixty percent of employees want to work
from home even if there is a vaccine one
two three days a week for all the
precautions he's taken Christian
Pinkston has found there's not actually
much enthusiasm among his staff for
returning to the office and we did an
anonymous survey of our staff a couple
of weeks ago and I was shocked by what I
found
they were not ready to come back and
there was still a lot of uncertainty a
lot of fear there's very much still
avoiding any unnecessary contact with
people that aren't you know family any
plan to get employees back to their
desks will have to include plenty of
reassurance a communication plan to let
people know what's being done to keep
them safe and flexibility to let them
decide when they're ready to come back
once we're opening the office to staff
it'll be on a as you're comfortable
basis will be sending out alerts when
clients or Outsiders will be in the
office we're going to be having staff
monitoring their temperatures and
symptoms and making decisions on a
day-by-day basis as to whether it's safe
for them to come in so lots of
communication and some confusion for
both employers and employees about when
to go back and how to go back who needs
a shake is a labor and employment lawyer
with Levitt LLP and she's in Richmond
Hill Ontario
manisa thanks for joining us returning
to work in a pandemic is new ground for
all of us what obligations broadly do
employers have when it comes to bringing
staff back into the office can they just
say we need you back and expect you to
show up well they can certainly say say
to their employees that they want you
back and we need you back but ultimately
whether or not employees have an
obligation to show up is largely
dependent on how safe the workplace is
now I will tell you that employers have
to follow much of the very same
guidelines that we're watching on TV as
they come down the pipeline through the
provincial government and direction from
the federal government around social
distancing where possible and sometimes
with certain jobs as you know it isn't
possible and providing appropriate
protective gear when social distancing
is not possible so unless employers
really understand that they need to step
up to the challenge and do their best to
keep their employees safe simply telling
them to return to return to work given
this current pandemic is not enough
what about employee rights can people be
forced back to the office if they feel
it's not safe where they're
uncomfortable about
so while your employer has an obligation
to keep you safe and healthy in the
workplace an employer does not have an
obligation to accommodate your stress
worrier angst because let's be honest
given the nature of this pandemic and
given much of what we've come to learn
in the past few weeks and months you
know there is no guarantee that you will
be fully insulated from this virus so as
long as your employer meets that
reasonable threshold in terms of keeping
you safe whether it's through social
distancing or protective gear may be
working from remotely in a staggered way
a lot of companies are doing that I know
our firm is doing that unless you know
as long as they are meeting that
threshold simply telling your employer
that look I understand that you're doing
all of these things but I'm still
worried I still don't want to come into
the workplace that simply is not good
enough from the employee perspective and
you could very well be faced with the
risk of being told by your employer that
because we have done everything that we
understand we need to do your refusal to
come into work at this point would
either be considered to be a resignation
or a job abandonment if that reasonable
threshold isn't reached though if
employees find that hygiene is
insufficient or physical distancing is
lacks are they stuck then or what can
they reasonably do at that point
they absolutely aren't stuck although I
can appreciate from a positional power
perspective that it's really difficult
to walk up to your employer and say hey
you know you're saying you're doing the
right things but I'm actually here and
it seems like you aren't in those
circumstances the employees most
certainly can file a complaint under the
Occupational Health and Safety Act I
know some of the Labor Relations
officers or ministry of labor officers
are responding pretty promptly to these
complaints that can be made anonymously
and they will come and check the
workplace out to see if indeed it's only
lip service or you know has the employer
actually implemented you know the social
distancing the protective gears and in
some cases it might be something as
simple as you know putting up signs and
reminders to employees you know in the
lunchroom perhaps or other areas where
employees tend to congregate
reminding them that social distancing is
to be observed at all times let's talk
about parents working from home who are
juggling work duties and looking after
young kids if they don't have access to
childcare schools not back for example
is that a legitimate reason to say I
can't come back to the office yet
it absolutely is a legitimate reason
under the human rights legislation there
is a protected ground which speaks to an
accommodation as far as it might relate
to family status and so if you as an
employer and many of my clients I've
said this to me has you know your
employees who are parents calling you
and saying look I understand that you're
not offering a remote option but under
no circumstances can I come back into
the workplace because I don't have
childcare in those circumstances what
you could expect is a job protective
leave that would be unpaid so your job
is safe
but the employer has no obligation to
pay you if you are home with your kids
this is as I said new ground for all of
us do you expect that there'll be lots
of test cases of employment law as this
pandemic continues absolutely and what
we have been saying to our clients
whether they are employer clients or
whether they're employee quiet clients
is this is unchartered territory for so
many of us including employment lawyers
so notwithstanding the fact that you
know we are giving certain legal advice
we've seen we've seen just a couple
weeks ago certain legislative changes
and I think some of these test cases
from an employment law perspective in
the coming months are really going to
map out for us what an accommodation
looks like what the employers
obligations are during a pandemic and
most importantly what is that reasonable
test in terms of keeping employees safe
in the workplace and those are specific
areas where I expect there to be a
significant amount of legal narrative
which could very well change the advice
some of the advice that we give to our
clients
[Music]